NOW I CAN DO THIS --
ENTERED THAT WILL BRING TO ORDER
--
THE THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC SAFETY
FIRST ITEM.
IS ARE AND WILL BEGIN AT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE. TO THE OTHER
MEMBERS COME --
FIRST AND ONLY ITEM IS AB FIVE
ONE FOUR OF SALAS [inaudible]
BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME --
TO BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE --
I DO WANNA PRESENT BEFORE YOU
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FOURTEEN
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO NOTIFY.
CHILD DAYCARE FACILITY ONE A
REGISTERED SEX OFFENDER REGISTER
AS A NEW RESIDENTS WITHIN A
THOUSAND FEET OF THE FACILITY.
THE MEASURE SEEKS TO EXPAND
PUBLIC AWARENESS OF AN ACCESS TO
AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
A REGARDING SEX OFFENDERS LIVING
IN THE COMMUNITY THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT WE WORKED OUT A
DILIGENTLY IN THE SENATE WITH --
MANY STAKEHOLDERS AND WOULD
APPRECIATE --
AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU OUR DEAR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
RT QUESTIONS FRM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE --
WE'RE WE'RE NOT QUITE A QUORUM
YET -- THE
CHAIR IS GOING TO RECOMMEND AN
AYE VOTE AND I WANT TO COMMEND
YOU.
ON THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
THINK IT WILL CLOSE OF A
LOOPHOLE.
THAT NOT ONLY YOU PUT YOU SEEN
IN YOUR DISTRICT --
I BELIEVED HER OTHER DISTRICTS
DEBT AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT WILL BENEFIT GREATLY WHEN
IT COMES TO US SEX OFFENDERS
BETTER IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD SO
I I COMMEND YOU ON BRING IN
THIS.
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FOR THAT
CREATE THAT THANK YOU MISTER
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND SO THEN WILL.
THEN WILL WAIT THE AND LET'S GET
A MOTION.
BECAME MOTION GRADUATE.
BY THEIR SHAPE THAT APPRECIATE
THIS WILL BE READ.
THAT.
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IF IS I HEAR PEOPLE TRYING TO
GET ANYWHERE [inaudible]
ALSO THE OPEN [inaudible]
I'VE.
WHAT WE HAVE [inaudible]
THE ESTABLISH A QUORUM NOW.
JONES SAWYER HERE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY [inaudible]
QUIRK [inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
WE HAVE A WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM [inaudible]
TUMBLR DUCKS.
THE MOTION TO APPROVE
[inaudible]
MR SECOND.
I WOULD A BE FIVE ONE FOUR
MOTION TO CONCUR ON SENATE
AMENDMENTS JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE.
LACKEY [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE I KILEY
[inaudible]
KILEY AYE [inaudible]
QUIRK.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
FILAMENTS ARE APPROVED
[inaudible]
CONGRATULATIONS AND WILL WAIT
FOR SOME AFTER MEMBERS.
TO COMMON AT ON THAT'S THE ONLY
VOTE
.
ON AB FIVE ONE FOUR GOTTI UP.
CUT YOUR AYE [inaudible]
THANK YOU
.
FAIRS RECOMMENDATION IS AN AYE
MR QUIRK.
MONEY AB FIVE ONE FOUR QUIRK
[inaudible]
QUIRK I THANK YOU MISTER QUIRK
.
I AB FIVE ONE FOUR LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE.
THANK YOU MUCH ELECTED.
NO PROBLEM AND WITH THAT WE
OFFICIALLY CLOSED THE ASSEMBLY
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE